diversity obviously a very big topic
right now your show is pretty similar to
Vanderpump rules they just let go of
four of their cast members for past
racial remarks and I would just love to
hear your take on that do you think it
was the right call and what do you think
can be learned from that experience what
happened there um I'll all go ahead
because I'm probably Vanderpump's one of
their biggest fans any mod I've seen
every episode saucy Schroder used to be
someone that I really looked up to and
then I read her book and I think they
definitely made the right call I think
any network that wants to make a impact
needs to hold people accountable for
their actions I'm not saying that they
shouldn't be forgiven but I think that
this opportunity that we have should be
for the right people and not what was it
about her book that changed your mind
about her um just very surface level
there's just there's not a lot of depth
to her I mean she owns that you know
like basic [ __ ] like she owns that but
I think that's the problem in this world
right now and I'll speak for girls is
we're so superficial we have to have
designer things designer bags and that
there's nothing wrong with having nice
things but that's not what life is about
there's so much more and my mind my
heart and my soul is so open right now
and I think there's some people I'm
talking about on Vanderpump that war
ever gonna get there I think Vanderpump
desperately trying to hold on to the
fact that they're young hot kids and all
of them were growing up but I think
Vanderpump rules clearly wants to try
and stay young they brought in a bunch
of new cast members so I think they're
just trying to revamp their show and I
think that's a good thing and I am gonna
be very very very sad not to watch saucy
and Bogut Mary
because I was their love story inspired
me a lot because I feel like I've kind
of a lot like her or at least used to be
and it was really special to see a man
like well look past that and love her
for her and I hope that they all grow
from this and I'm sure they will you
know it's sad Erika it is sad but I
think it was necessary do you think the
show should be totally canceled do you
think Jack should be fired off the show
- I are so familiar with the show and
what's been happening I think that a lot
of their old cast members need to go
besides the Tom's Katie and Ariana I
think everyone else should move on with
their lives
okay I don't think it's good for them
mentally I mean look at Jax this season
like mentally like they need to be done
they've been doing this for over 10
years right only been doing it for three
and like I'm not okay
like I really struggled I'm okay now but
I just like I think that they were the
first to be a part of this girl then
they need to put their mental health
first yeah do you guys think that your
own show needs to be more diverse I
think so hundred percent yeah how do we
make how does that happen or how do you
make that I've cried myself to sleep
over the fact that I feel like I have
talked to black people more in the last
three weeks and I have in my whole life
and that's really um a hard thing to
swallow um so it's just about like I
don't want anything force like we all
just Garrett has a ton of friends of all
races because he's always played sports
oh yeah I really want to like you know
with that being said like I have like I
grew up around like the black community
have tons of black friends that I grew
up with so I'm always with the I have
you in mind
friend will who lives when he's black so
like you know I'm always with them and
it's a positive thing to you know be
kind to everybody no matter what color
they are what race they are I've always
grown up that way I'm hoping that you
know I could bring some of my friends
you know that did play sports with me I
still do play sports to you know create
that diversity in our shows I definitely
think we do need to be more diverse and
I think that we should definitely start
doing that and we have a lot of friends
that we could include it's just hard
when there's so many different people
and so many different stories and stuff
like that it's hard for them to get it
all you know yeah I agree I think the
whole black lives matter movement has
like made us realize like wow we are
like very white and privileged and like
we need to have more voices of color and
have black people to you know express
themselves on our show as well so it is
definitely eye-opening and I think we
all agree that we want you know to to
have more diversity yeah
your guys's show is pretty similar to
Vanderpump rules and they just let go of
two of their main characters that have
been with the show since season one and
four little did you guys think that was
the right called I think that they did
make the right call I think that this
whole movement has been so amazing and
everything is I feel like we're actually
starting to change like our entire
culture everything about our society I
think it's going in the right direction
right now and I think they didn't make
the right call and I think that Madison
and I have both learned a lot from this
I there were things I didn't even know
that I did there were so there was so
much stuff we had to learn and there
were people I noticed until I educated
myself I didn't realize that they were
wrong also
so yeah they definitely made the right
call and I think it it makes us realize
like we need to use our platforms to
like amplify
the voices of color and black people and
like use our platforms for good
[Music]